things that you enjoy you will be  previous predisposed to repeat them and  want to do them unfortunately we have  turned running into this thing where if  it feels good we're probably doing it  wrong you know it should feel bad we  should be by ourselves we should be  racing our Strava I mean we think about  in evolutionary terms we evolve to run  as hunting packs in concert with other  people and you feel it you've never had  a run with a buddy that felt bad you  never came back that was a bad idea the  bigger the group The more fun it is and  what we're finding again and again is if  we actually embrace those tadamata  evolutionary Roots family and fun and  incorporate into our workouts the  results are amazing